Earth is 4.5 billion years old – impossible
for your brain to truly grasp, so here is an experiment:
every second around 1.5 million years
will pass – you're on a musical train ride
looking out the window, passing all of
Earth's History in an hour.
Watch the eons pass and experience
how long a billion years really is.
You can have this in the background, study
with it or just enjoy the ride.
From time to time, I’ll say a few words.
4.5 billion years ago, right after it was
born, Earth was a hell of lava…
Pretty early in its history, Earth collides
with a Mars sized object called Theia,
which forms the moon that you now see in the sky.
Right now it looks huge in the night sky and
will slowly shrink over hundreds of millions
of years as it orbits further away.
4.5 Billion Years Ago we are in the first eon of our planet, the Hadean, named after the greek god of the underworld.
At this point the Atmosphere is mostly CO2
and the floor is lava.
This area of earth's history is mostly invisible
to us because almost none of it is left.
90 million years have passed.
We are still in the lava hell phase.
Settle in, this will take a while.
Although you wouldn't think it, we found
minerals called zircons that indicate
there may have been some
water around at this time.
During this period of the young solar system,
Earth and the inner solar system are smashed
by a constant heavy asteroid bombardment,
for several hundred million years.
At this point in time, our Sun is 30% less
bright than it is today but there are so many
greenhouse gases that it's
still much hot and comfy.
Around this time we think
life begins to enter the stage.
Only a few hundred million years after the
beginning of everything the first cells begin
spreading over our still very deadly planet.
Earth continues to cool and it probably
rains for millions of years
as our oceans begin to form, covering
the still young planet with water.
These hydrothermal vents we're looking at,
and where hot minerals emerge, may have been
the place where life first developed,
but we dont know.
So much time has passed and we are entering
the Paleoarchean.
Most of Earth is still underwater while the
first supercontinents are in the making
in the depths below.
Its days are shorter since the
young Earth spins faster.
Good job if you are still watching.
You witnessed a billion years so far.
From this time in history we still have Stromatolites,
sedimentary rocks built by microorganisms.
Among our first real evidence of life on Earth.
Also life is starting to eat the sun – photosynthesis
might have started as early as around here.
3.2 Billion Years Ago in the Mesoarchean the
era of continents begins.
Tectonic plates begin to crush into each other,
pulling and pushing some deep into the earth
where they dissolve.
The basis for our continents today.
The oceans are as hot as a hottub, over 40°C
and microbes are expanding everywhere.
We don't have plants yet to consume greenhouse
gases, so it is really, really hot.
You would basically die immediately
in this atmosphere.
Also there is no oxygen
in the atmosphere yet.
2.8 Billion Years Ago the Neoarchean begins.
Earth is still a terribly hostile place but
because we finally have proper plate tectonics,
more chemicals are mixed in from inside the
earth and life can use them to make new things!
Some time around here Prokaryotes like bacteria
begin colonizing the planet.
Life diversifies more and more.
But still, after so much time,
we only have single cells.
2.5 Billion Years Ago in the Siderian,
a massive event is about to begin
that will change the planet forever:
The Great Oxidation Event.
Oxygen, burped out by cyanobacteria reaches
the atmosphere in large quantities,
paving the way for more complex life.
All the new oxygen in the air reacts with
methane and forms CO2 and Water,
which rapidly cools the planet down.
Probably for the first time ever, the planet
freezes over and a period of multiple
ice ages begins lasting millions of years.
2.3 Billion Years Ago the Rhyacian begins.
Lots of volcanos heat up earth and
earth unfreezes slowly again.
Melting ice flushes toxic elements into the
oceans but life quietly puts up resistance
and keeps evolving.
Some time 2.05 Billion Years Ago in the Orosirian
a large asteroid hits earth and creates the
largest verified impact structure on Earth.
All over Earth great mountain ranges are
crushed into existence by early continents
with wild names like Ur, Nena or Atlantica.
1.8 Billion Years Ago in the Statherian
the supercontinent Columbia has formed.
And a natural, self sustaining
nuclear reactor awakes,
just from scattered uranium
deposits in the ground.
1.6 billion years ago, around the edge of
Calimmian, + or - a few hundred million years or so,
the first Eukaryotic cells, cells with
a nucleus, merge from two other cells.
One of the most important
moments in the history of life.
But yes, kind of looks not that impressive.
Still, life is only cells.
Earth's crust thickens and heavy continents
form, the oceans become shallower.
Also the first fungi-like organisms extent
their tubular arms and do fungi things.
Some time in the Ectasian 1.4 Billion Years
Ago, Earths inner core is forming.
Weird, right? Feels like it should be older.
But around here it begins to solidify into
a iron crystal surrounded by hot liquid metal.
It will only grow from now on.
1.2 Billion Years Ago in the Stenian not that
much is going on.
Except, the algae Bangiomorpha
pubescens might have invented sex.
A big reproductive improvement
for many different reasons.
1 Billion Years Ago the Tonian begins, another
age where Earth is rocks and puddles and oceans.
Life is still invisible to the naked eye.
It does feel different to
witness it like that, right?
Not everybody is having a great time here.
We have evidence of the first unicellular
predators emerging around that time.
The dominance of bacteria ends and big boy
eukaryotes plant their flags in the oceans.
An arms race between microbes begins that
again creates huge diversity.
Some even invent tiny armour.
720 Million Years Ago in the Cryogenian
Earth freezes over again.
Sure why not.
How did life survive?
We are not sure.
635 Million Years Ago the supercontinent
Gondwana forms.
A lot of it is still left today!
Wow! What's happening?
Suddenly life gets big!
In a hot second multicellular
organisms become widespread!
It's all strange aliens still, but can you
imagine that it took that long for this to happen?
539 Million Years Ago the
Cambrian explosion begins.
We see life bursting with variety.
Ancestors of almost all of today's major animal
groups appear here while the plants start
to discover the land.
Life is finally exciting!
But of course a big mass extinction happens
right after, killing most species in the ocean.
Plants spread over the planet and create the
soil on the ground and change the atmosphere
by eating CO2.
Things escalate.
Flora and fauna adapt better
and better to life on land.
We get trees and forrests, fish and the
first vertebrate decide this land thing
is something they need to try out!
359 Million Years Ago in the Carboniferous
forests and lush marshlands are at their peak.
They will turn into the coal humanity burns
today to keep ourselves warm.
Its all so fast now!
Life changes so quickly
in geological timeframes!
Some 299 Million Years Ago in the Permian,
Pangea, the last supercontinent has formed.
And after a few tens of million years, the
largest mass extinction in history happens,
killing the majority of all species.
Thanks volcanoes.
252 Million Years Ago the Triassic begins.
Oh hey, a dinosaur!
We are now truly in the age of reptiles.
Dinosaurs are everywhere!
The ancestors of the birds do bird things.
Life, uhh, finds a way!
Earth gets more and more familiar.
Such a paradise.
Life is thriving.
Nothing can go wrong... wait, what's that?
And an asteroid killed the dinosaurs and
most species on Earth.
Such a bummer.
66 Million Years Ago in the Paleogene
the continents look roughly the same as today
and mammals take over.
It is our time now!
We are almost home.
Don't blink or you might miss
all of human history!
And that was it.
Earth is ancient.
We are new.
So new.
This was a project born of passion.
We've worked on this video on and off since
2019 and as you can imagine, it took forever to make.
But we did we finished it in time
for our tenth10 year anniversary.
If you want to support experimental videos
like this one please like, share and subscribe
and press the bell.
You can also continue your journey through
time with our new Timeline of Evolution poster.
Discover how long it took for the first cellular
blobs to evolve into fishes, then into dinosaurs,
and finally into mammals – and encounter
amazing creatures you've never heard of along the way.
This poster is part of our Education Edition.
A poster series that brings complex topics
to life through extensive research and
elaborate illustrations.
It’s perfect for teachers, students,
and science lovers.
Get them from our shop and support what we
do on this channel.
In any case, if you got this far,
thank you so much!
Hope you felt something watching this.